THE ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN SESSION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRO NOTICES THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA.
BAUER-KAHAN BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BURNER **** BATH [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CALDERON CARILLO.
CERVANTES CHAU.
CHEN.
DAVID CHIU.
CHOI.
KANSEN CHU COOLEY.
COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM DALY.
DALY.
DEEP [inaudible]
EGGMAN FLORA.
FONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN.
GABRIEL.
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ GRAY.
GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER.
KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE.
LOW MOAN LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY
MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI.
NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL
PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK
QUIRK SILVA.
RAMOS RAY IS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO.
SALAS SANTIAGO.
SMITH STONE [inaudible]
TING VOEPEL [inaudible]
WALDRON [inaudible]
WEBER.
WICKS.
WOOD MISTER SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK THAT OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER.
AND IN THE GALLERY PLEASE STAND
FOR THE PRAYER.
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER
THANK YOU.
DAYS PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED BY
OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN REVEREND
PATTY -- STUFF REMOVED.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
I AM WORRIED.
THAT OUR PUBLIC CONSCIENCE WAS
GROWING NUMB TO LINES BEING
CALLED.
MISS REMEMBERED FAX IN THAT
PERPETRATORS OF MISDEEDS.
WERE BEING WERE NOT BEING HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR ACTIONS.
THE RECENT COLLEGE BRIBERY
SCANDAL HIGHLIGHTED ANOTHER
SCHEME. FOR THOSE WITH MEANS
FELT THEIR RULES DO NOT APPLY TO
THEM.
BUT ONCE THE BRIBERY SCHEME WAS
REVEALED.
THOSE INVOLVED WERE REMINDED THE
INTEGRITY MATTERS.
JOBS WERE LOST IN REPUTATIONS
DAMAGED. ONE WELL KNOWN ACTRESS
INVOLVED IN THE COLLEGE BRIBERY
SCANDAL SAID IN IN AN INSPIRING
INTERVIEW LAST YEAR.
MONEY IS NOT IMPORTANT.
DOING THE RIGHT THING IS WHAT
COUNTS.
HER SHOWS HAVE SEVER THEIR TIES
WITH HER.
IN ANNOUNCED AS SHE DOES NOT
REPRESENT THE INTEGRITY OF THEIR
BROWN.
THIS RECENT COLLEGE BRIBERY
SCANDAL IT'S A GREAT REMINDER
THAT TRUTH IN INTEGRITY AND
HONESTY ARE NOT JUST WORDS.
THESE ARE VALUES THAT WILL
DEFINE WHO WE ARE AT THE VERY
CORE OF OUR BEING.
AS THE AUTHOR CS LEWIS WROTE.
INTEGRITY IS DOING THE RIGHT
THING.
EVEN WHEN NO ONE IS WATCHING.
IN OTHER WORDS AT THE HEART OF
WHO WE ARE.
WILL BE THE INTEGRITY WITH WHICH
WE HAVE LIVED.
NUMBER ONE THE NUMBER TWO WITH
KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE BEYOND
WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING.
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WICKS AS HE AS HE LEADS US IN
THE PLEDGE MISS WICKS.
PLEASE PLACE YOUR RIGHT HAND
OVER YOUR HEART READY BEGIN.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO OUR CLASS.
WHICH IT STANDS.
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE.
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY MARCH
THIRTEENTH TWENTY NINETEEN
RECENTLY MET AT SEVEN AM ON WILL
STEVEN CHOI ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SIXTIETH DISTRICT PRESIDING
CHIEF QUICKIE DOTSON WILSON AT
THE DESK.
READING CLICK APPLICATION --
BONTA MOVES AND MISS WALDRON
SECONDS THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS HAVE PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION TO REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
JUST FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE ARE
NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY FOR LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JESSE GABRIEL.
FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
[inaudible]
CALDERON COOPER.
DALY.
AND CHEN.
MEMBERS WE ARE PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS MR.
BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
PROCEDURE MOTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS KILEY SALAS.
AND QUIRK SILVA TO HAVE GUESTS
AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR
TODAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK
SILVA AS GUEST.
WILL BE SEATED AT HER DESK.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE AND ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS RAMOS O'DONNELL GIPSON
RADIUS.
AND PATTERSON TO SPEAK ON AN
ADJOURNMENT IN MEMORY TODAY.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO RE REFER TO THE FOLLOWING
BILLS TO COMMITTEE.
AB ONE SEVEN SIX CERVANTES FROM
THE NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE
TO THE RULES COMMITTEE.
A. B. EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT LOW FROM
THE HEALTH COMMITTEE TO THE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE AND THEN BACK. TO
HEALTH COMMITTEE AND A. B.
TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN OBERNOLTE
FROM THE WATER PARKS AND
WILDLIFE COMMITTEE TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
PLEASE REMOVE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
FIVE A. C. R. THIRTY ONE LIMON.
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THE CLERK WILL NOTE.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS TO
USE A PROP DURING HIS GUEST
INTRODUCTION TODAY.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE SPECIAL GUEST
WITH US IN THE ASSEMBLY TODAY
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
PLEASE GIVE ATTENTION TO MISTER
KILEY MISTER KILEY HAS SPECIAL
GUESTS WITH US TODAY.
THERE IS I'M GOING TO RECOGNIZE
MISTER KILEY.
FROM MY DESK IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER [inaudible]
MR KILEY.
MR KILEY ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
JOINING ME ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR
TODAY IS A VERY SPECIAL GUEST.
CANINE EROS OF THE PLASTER
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT.
BORN IN FRANCE EROS BEGAN HIS
LAW ENFORCEMENT CAREER WITH THE
STOCKTON POLICE DEPARTMENT.
ENJOYING THE PASTA COUNTY
SHERIFF'S OFFICE IN TWO THOUSAND
AND TWELVE ON JANUARY FIFTEENTH
OF THIS YEAR.
A DERANGED CRIMINAL WITH NO TIES
TO POSTURE COUNTY.
MURDERED A NINETY THREE YEAR OLD
WOMAN.
AND THEN PROCEEDED TO BECOME A
ROLLING ACTIVE SHOOTER.
HE SHOT AND INJURED A MAN WHO
WAS DRIVING WITH A SEVEN YEAR
OLD DAUGHTER AND PUT MANY OTHER
LIVES IN DANGER.
PLUS A COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPUTIES
SET OFF IN PURSUIT ALONG WITH
OTHER LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THE SHOOTER EVENTUALLY CRASHES
VEHICLE IN ROSEVILLE AND ROLLED
OFF THE FREEWAY ON RAMP.
AS HE WAS CORNERED HE WANTED TO
CONTINUE HIS KILLING SPREE BY
SHOOTING AT MEMBERS OF THE
PLASTER COUNTY SHERIFF'S OFFICE
ROOSEVELT POLICE DEPARTMENT.
ROCKLIN POLICE DEPARTMENT AND
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL.
AT THIS POINT.
EROS WAS DEPLOYED IN AN ATTEMPT
TO SUBDUE THE VIOLENT SUSPECT.
IN THE MIDST OF THE APPREHENSION.
EROS WAS SHOT AND BADLY WOUNDED.
FORTUNATELY WITH THE QUICK
THINKING OF HIS HANDLER AND THE
STAFF AT THE VET.
HE RECEIVED PROP FRIEDMAN.
AT EROS WAS SAVED.
I SAW THE HEART RENDING PHOTOS
OF EROS IS WOUNDS AS HE
RECOVERED FROM HIS INJURIES.
BUT RECOVER HE DID.
AS OF MARCH THIRD WE ARE
THANKFUL TO REPORT THAT CANINE
EROS HAS RETURNED TO FULL DUTY
PROTECTING THE RESIDENTS OF
PLASTER COUNTY.
THIS TERRIBLE INCIDENT.
IS A REMINDER OF SOMETHING WE
SHOULD ALWAYS REMEMBER.
THERE ARE MEN AND WOMEN AND YES
CANINES AS WELL.
IN LAW ENFORCEMENT PUT THEIR
LIVES ON THE LINE EVERY SINGLE
DAY. FOR THE SAFETY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES AND THE PROTECTION
OF OUR CONSTITUENTS AND THEY
DESERVE THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF
RESPECT COMMENDATION AND SUPPORT.
FROM THE MEMBERS OF THIS BODY.
JOINING ME TODAY ON THE FLOOR IS
PASTA COUNTY'S OUTSTANDING SHARE.
DEVON BELL.
UNDERSHERIFF WHEN WE PUBLIC
INFORMATION OFFICER ANGELA MISS
ALL ON SERGEANT JOHN SCOFIELD
THE CANINE UNIT SERGEANT.
DEPUTY KEVIN THOMPSON WHOSE EROS
IS HANDLER AND OF COURSE EROS
HIMSELF.
IN THE GALLERY OUR CAPTAIN TROY
SANDER LIEUTENANT JASON LOCKHART
LIEUTENANT BRIAN SILVA DEPUTY TO
BIAS WILLIAMS DEPUTY STANCE Là
SOME A NEW.
DEPUTY MCCALL YOUR MILIEU DEPUTY
GLENN RYDELL OFFICER TRINA
BENDER OFFICER APRIL WOULDN'T
OFFICER CHRIS OLIVER DEPUTY NOTE
FREDERICO AND DEPUTY RICH
CERVANTES.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SACRIFICE FELLOW
MEMBERS OF THE STATE ASSEMBLY I
ASK YOU TO JOIN ME IN WELCOMING
THESE DISTINGUISHED GUESTS TO
OUR CHAMBER
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE ADDITIONAL GAS
IN THE CHAMBER TODAY FORGET HAVE
YOUR ATTENTION MEMBERS.
MR OBERNOLTE YOU HAVE GUESTS
WITH US TODAY THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES IT IS MY
HONOR TO INTRODUCE YOU TO THE
NEW CHIEF FOR THE SAN MARINO
COUNTY FIRE DEPARTMENT CHIEF DON
TRAP.
HE HAS BEEN LEADING THE
DEPARTMENT OF SINCE JANUARY SAN
MARINO COUNTY FIRE HAS A LONG
HISTORY OF EXCELLENCE AND FIRE
SUPPRESSION AND I HAVE NO DOUBT
THAT UNDER CHIEF TRAP THEY WILL
CONTINUE THAT LEGACY.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING TO
THE ASSEMBLY.
AND MS QUIRK SILVA YOU HAVE A
SPECIAL GUEST WITH US ON THE
FLOOR.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO LET YOU
KNOW ABOUT AN INDIVIDUAL WHO
SPENDS HIS DAY WITH OVER A
HUNDRED JUNIOR HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS.
AT TEACHING ENTREPRENEURSHIP AND
MATH AND ALSO IN HIS SPARE TIME
LEADS THE CITY OF FULLERTON AS
THE MAYOR MY HUSBAND HATES TO
SILVA
.
AND MR SALAS.
YOU HAVE GAS IN THE CHAMBER
MISTER SALAS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FROM YOUR DESK.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I COULD HAVE YOUR ATTENTION JUST
FOR A MOMENT PLEASE.
AB MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE
A VERY SPECIAL GROUP TO THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
THEY ARE STUDENTS FROM JOHN MUIR
MIDDLE SCHOOL OR CORPORATE ON ME
TELL YOU ONE OF THE COOL THINGS
ABOUT THE STUDENTS. ONE YOU
MIGHT NOTICE THEY'RE ALL.
THEY'RE ALL YOUNG LADIES.
BUT SECONDLY IS THERE ONE OF THE
ONLY FEW SCHOOLS ACROSS THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY.
NOT JUST THIS COUNTRY BUT THE U.
S. CANADA AND BRAZIL TO BE
SELECTED TO SEND AN EXPERIMENT
UP INTO SPACE.
AND THAT'S THE EXPERIMENT THAT
GOES WITH A NASA ASTRONAUT.
NOT ONLY DID THEY GET SELECTED
TO DO THIS WITH VISION TWELVE
BUT THEY GOT SELECTED AGAIN THIS
YEAR.
PROVISION THIRTEEN SO I'D LIKE
YOU TO PLEASE.
JOIN ME IN WELCOMING MISSION
TWELVE AND HOW WE CAN LOSE
MEDINA.
LUPITA NOON YES LISA FERNANDEZ
O'DONNELL.
MONTHS RENT MALL MALDONADO FOR
MISSION THIRTEEN CATALINA LEONA
SERVICE I NEVER GOT LOOSE MEDINA
MONEY ON A MORE THAN ALL.
ON THE LEASE.
THE VENAL.
ROSALYN GAINED GARCIA THE
MEMBERS I'D ALSO LIKE.
TO USE PROP MISTER SPEAKER
[inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SO WE ALSO HAVE SOME MISSION
PATCHES HERE THAT I'D LIKE
EVERYBODY.
TO COME LOOK AT THESE ARE THE
MISSION PATCHES.
OR THEIR DESIGNATED MISSIONS I
WENT UP INTO SPACE AND SO PLEASE
MEMBERS IF YOU'LL JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING THEM THERE ARE MANY OF
THEM THEIR FIRST TIME TO THE
STATE CAPITOL
[inaudible]
AND MEMBERS.
WE HAVE ONE REMAINING GROUP OF
GAS MR TANG.
MR TAKE YOU HAVE GUESTS THAT
HAVE JOINED US IN THE GALLERY
MEMBERS.
PLEASE KEEP THE VOLUME LEVEL
MANAGEABLE MISTER TING YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I AM
HONORED TO WELCOME.
THE STUDENTS FROM ST IGNATIUS
COLLEGE PREPARATORY.
THE COULD PLEASE STAND ARE THEY
HERE.
CONGRATULATIONS THEY RECENTLY
JUST GOT RANKED AS ONE OF THE
TOP TWENTY FIVE INDEPENDENT.
ALL HIGH SCHOOLS IN -- THE BAY
AREA BY THE SAN FRANCISCO
BUSINESS TIMES SO WELCOME TO
SACRAMENTO CONGRATULATIONS FOR
BEING HERE.
I GOT THE NOTE OR OR SPEAKER PRO
TERMS -- WIFE IS A VERY
DISTINGUISHED ALUMNI AND HE'S
SPORTING THE RIGHT COLORS TODAY
SO THANK YOU.
MEMBERS.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
ASSEMBLY A SECOND READING.
COOKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTY SEVEN FIVE
NINETY SEVEN THREE NINETEEN WITH
MA'AM IT'S TWO OH FIVE AND FOUR
TWENTY SIX AT THE MOMENT.
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
THERE IS WE ARE MOVING TO
ASSEMBLY.
THIRD READING.
WE WILL TAKE AB FILE ITEM NUMBER.
SIX THIS IS H. R..
FOURTEEN BY DR EGGMAN COOKERY.
HOUSE RESOLUTION FOURTEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN RELATIVE
TO SOCIAL WORK MONTH.
DOCTOR EGGMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT HR
FOURTEEN TO COMMIT COMMEMORATE
MARCH AS SOCIAL WORKER MONTH.
ONE OF THE BEST MONTHS WE HAVE
WOMEN'S MONTH WE HAVE MY
BIRTHDAY WE HAVE SOCIAL WORK
MONTH EVERYTHING JUST SEEMS TO
COME TOGETHER IN MARCH -- AS WE
SPRING INTO A NEW SEASON -- AND
CELEBRATE ALL THINGS THAT CAN
GROW TO THE TOP OF THEIR
POTENTIAL AND THAT'S WHAT SOCIAL
WORKERS DO MEMBERS THEY HELPED
CREATE THE ENVIRONMENT SO THAT
INDIVIDUALS ARE ABLE TO REMOVE
OBSTACLES TO DIGNITY.
SO THAT THEY CAN MOVE AND GROW
TO THEIR FULL POTENTIAL.
THE SOCIAL WAS STARTED BY A
WOMAN NAMED JANE ADAMS WHO WAS
ONE OF THE FIRST ONE WAS ONE WAS
THE FIRST WOMAN. TO RECEIVE THE
NOBEL PEACE PRIZE -- SHE'S
CONSIDERED THE MOTHER OF SOCIAL
WORK STARTED WORKING IN THE
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES IN
SETTLEMENT HOUSES AND YOU'LL
STILL FIND SOCIAL WORKERS WHERE
THERE ARE VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
ALL OVER THE WORLD.
ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF CLIENTS
AND SYSTEMS AND FAMILIES AND
GROUPS. TO TRY TO MAKE THE WORLD
A BETTER PLACE -- AS WE GO OUT
MEMBERS AS WE CAN I WAS OUT ON
AG TOUR I INVITE ALL OF YOU WHEN
YOUR HOME IN YOUR DISTRICTS TO
DO -- SOCIAL WORK TOUR WE CAN
BEFORE WE CAN BE FOUND IN
PRISONS IN SCHOOLS IN.
IN YOUR COUNTY OFFICES IN CP US
ALL OVER DOING THE WORK THAT NOT
A LOT OF FOLKS WANT TO DO.
BUT BECAUSE WE'RE CALLED TO TRY
TO MAKE THE WORLD A BETTER PLACE --
WE STEP UP AND DO THAT AND WOULD
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT.
TODAY THERE ARE OVER SIXTY EIGHT
THOUSAND SOCIAL WORKERS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WITH MORE
THAN EIGHT THOUSAND GRADUATE
STUDENTS -- CURRENTLY GOING
THROUGH PROGRAMS -- I WOULD ASK
THE FIRST ROLE TO BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS AND IN THE GALLERY I
WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE MERCY
GONZALEZ WHO IS THE LEGISLATIVE
COORDINATOR FOR ANY AS TO BE
CALIFORNIA.
THERE SHE IS UP THERE.
YOUR TESTIFYING -- SO MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
AND MADE THE FIRST ROLE BE OPEN
FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK.
THANK YOU DOCTOR EGGMAN.
SEE NO DISCUSSION.
ON THE RESOLUTION.
DOCTOR EGGMAN IS ASKING THAT
FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
CLICK WELL CLOSE RATHER SIXTY
EIGHT CO AUTHORS ADDED.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION.
IS ADOPTED.
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
SEVEN THIS IS A BE TO EIGHTEEN
FOR THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS.
CLERK WILL READ WITH AMENDMENTS
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO EIGHTEEN WITH
AMENDMENTS BY FAMILY MEMBER
GONZALEZ.
THIS IS ALSO ON THE AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU.
AB TWO EIGHTEEN WOULD EXTEND THE
CIVIL STATURE LIMITATIONS FOR
VICTIMS OF CHILDHOOD SEXUAL
ASSAULT FROM AGE TWENTY SIX TO
AGE FORTY AND IN CASES OF DELAY
DISCOVERY FROM THREE YEARS AFTER
DISCOVERY.
TO FIVE AMENDMENTS HIS BILL AT A
CO AUTHOR AND MAKE A GRAMMATICAL
CHANGE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS GONZALEZ.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS
ARE ADOPTED BILLS OUT TO PRINT.
AND BACK ON FILE PASS RETAIN ON
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHT WE ARE AT FILE ITEM NUMBER
NINE THIS IS H. R..
TWENTY ONE CORKERY.
HOUSE RESOLUTION TWENTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER RELATIVE
TO DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
AWARENESS MONTH.
MR FRAZIER EMAIL BUT THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING OUR
FRIENDS IN THE GALLERY WHO ARE
HERE TODAY.
IN RECOGNITION OF DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AWARENESS MONTH.
I AM PLEASED TO RECOGNIZE STAFF
CONSUMERS.
ADVOCATES FAMILY AND FRIENDS
FROM STATE AND NONPROFIT
AGENCIES IN THE X. INTELLECTUAL
AND DISABILITY COMMUNITY.
THESE GREAT REPRESENTATIVES DO
THE HARD ADVOCACY WORK THAT
ENLIGHTENS AND EDUCATES US ALL.
THEY'RE WORKING ON BEHALF OF
THIS SPECIAL POPULATION.
THAT I HOLD DEAR.
THEY HAVE SERVE THE POPULATION
SO NOBLY. FOR SO MANY YEARS.
BEING UNDER FUNDED AND I THANK
THEM FOR THEIR SERVICE.
WE HAVE REPRESENTED HERE TODAY
THE STATE COUNCIL ON
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
[inaudible]
FUTURES EXPLORED.
DISABILITY VOICES UNITED.
THE CALIFORNIA DISABILITY
SERVICES SO SEE ATION.
COMMUNITY ACTION NETWORK.
THE ASSOCIATION OF REGIONAL
CENTERS.
AGENCIES.
AND THE ARK OF CALIFORNIA.
IT'S WONDERFUL TO SEE SUCH A
LARGE GROUP.
AND I WANT TO THANK THEM FOR
COMING IN PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING THEM TO THE ASSEMBLY
CHAMBERS [inaudible]
WITH THAT.
WISH YOU WOULD RECOGNIZE THESE
WONDERFUL PEOPLE.
MISS FRAZIER WE WILL RECOGNIZE.
MEMBERS WE WILL RECOGNIZE GAS
ONCE WE'VE TAKEN A VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION.
MR LACKEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
YEAH MISTER SPEAKER COLLEAGUES
JUST REAL QUICKLY I STAND
SUPPORT OF THIS VERY OF VALUABLE
MEASURE HR TWENTY ONE TO
INCREASE.
THE AWARENESS AND ACCEPTANCE OF
PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
ADVOCATING ON BEHALF OF THIS
pTRUE PASSIONS EVER SINCE
STUDYING.
SPECIAL EDUCATION IN COLLEGE.
THE DEVELOPMENT A DISABLED
COMMUNITY IS TRADITIONALLY BEEN
OVERLOOKED.
AND UNDERSERVED AND I LIKE TO
THINK MY MY COLLEAGUE FROM
DISCOVERY BAY. FOR ALLOWING US
TO VOTE ON THIS RESOLUTION AND
AND PROVIDE THIS RECOGNITION
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER LACKING SEEN
NOTATIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
THIS FRAZIER YOU WOULD LIKE CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO OPEN THE
ROLE FOR CO AUTHORS ON HR TWENTY
ONE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THE CLERK WELL CLOSER ALL THEIR
SEVEN EIGHT ONE CO AUTHORS ADDED
AND WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE HOUSE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED AND AGAIN ON BEHALF
OF MR FRAZIER WE WELCOME GAS.
FROM STATE NONPROFIT AGENCIES IN
THE ID DE COMMUNITY WILL JOIN US
IN THE CHAMBER TODAY LET'S
WELCOME THEM TO THE ASSEMBLY
.
MEMBERS AND FILE ORDER FILE
ITEMS TEN ELEVEN AND TWELVE PASS
RETAIN.
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
THIRTEEN THIS IS AB. FIFTY FOUR
BY MR TANG.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING AND
ACTUALLY THE PEACE OFFICERS TO
CLAIM THE URGENCY THERE UP TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
MR TANG YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MUCH MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER I AB FIFTY FOUR CORRECTS
A DRAFTING ERROR FROM LAST YEAR.
LAST YEAR WE PASSED THE A. B.
SEVEN FORTY WHICH OUR BODY
CAMERA LEGISLATION.
UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE OF THE
SEVEN TO OUR ROLE WE WERE NOT
ABLE TO MAKE AMENDMENTS BEFORE
TAKING UP ON THE FLOOR.
SO THIS MINOR DRAFTING ERROR WE
ASK THAT YOU.
VOTE I SO THAT WE CAN CORRECT A.
B. SEVEN FORTY WHICH TO GET
SIGNED BY GOVERNOR BROWN
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I THOUGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER KING.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
QUIRK LIBERAL ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTE
AYE AYES IXTY THREE KNOWS THREE
ON THE URGENCY.
AYE AYES SIXTY THREE KNOWS.
THREE ON THE BILL THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS WHERE FILE ITEM FOURTEEN
AB.
TWO OH TWO CALGARY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO OH TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MATHIS AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY TO ENDANGERED
SPECIES.
MR MATHIS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS -- AB TWO OH TO
JUST SIMPLY REMOVES THE SUNSET
FROM THE SAFE HARBOR ACT THIS IS
A PROGRAM THAT'S BEEN WORKING
OUT VERY WELL -- AND NO REASON
FOR THERE TO BE A SUNSET ON ANY
LONGER ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MATHIS.
SEE NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
ON THIS ITEM.
CLICK LIBERAL ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL AND TELL YOU WHAT I
SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEMS FIFTEEN AND SIXTEEN
PASS RETAIN.
MEMBERS WERE FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTEEN AC ARE FIFTY THREE BY
MISTER RACING CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FIFTY THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON IT RELATIVE TO DOWN
SYNDROME AWARENESS.
MR RACE AND YOU MAY OPEN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES.
TODAY I RISE TO INTRODUCE ACR
FIFTY THREE HONORING CALIFORNIA
DOWN SYNDROME AWARENESS DAY AND
WEEK.
MARCH SEVENTEENTH TWO TWENTY
FOURTH WAS CALIFORNIA DOWN
SYNDROME WEAK.
AND MARCH TWENTY FIRST TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN WAS CALIFORNIA
DOWN SYNDROME AWARENESS DAY.
AND MAY I TAKE THIS MOMENT TO
THANK EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU
AS MY COLLEAGUES AS WELL AS THE
CAPITAL STAFF. FOR YOUR KINDNESS --
AS MY SISTER WITH DOWN SYNDROME
VISITED WITH ME LAST WEEK AND
SPENT TIME WITH ME ON THE FLOOR.
DOWN SYNDROME IS A CHROMOSOMAL
DISORDER THAT OCCURS IN ONE OUT
OF EVERY SEVEN HUNDRED TO ONE
THOUSAND BIRDS AND AFFECTS ALL
RACES AND ETHNICITIES.
DESPITE THEIR CHROMOSOMAL
DIFFERENCES INDIVIDUALS WITH
DOWN SYNDROME ATTEND SCHOOL WORK
PARTICIPATE IN DECISIONS THAT
AFFECT THEM HAVE MEANINGFUL
RELATIONSHIPS THEY VOTE AND
CONTRIBUTE TO SOCIETY AND MANY
MANY WONDERFUL WAYS.
HERE ARE JUST A FEW EXAMPLES OF
THEIR PROFESSIONAL SUCCESSES AND
THE PAST DECADE IN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN THE FIRST WOMAN WITH
DOWN SYNDROME WAS ELECTED TO
VALUE -- TO LEAD CITY COUNCIL IN
SPAIN ONE WOMAN WAS -- HAS
TRAVELED THE WORLD IS AN
INSPIRATIONAL SPEAKER AND IS
DECORATED AS A GOLD MEDAL WINNER
IN SKIING SWIMMING AND CYCLING.
THIS SAME AMAZING INDIVIDUAL
ALSO TEACHES READING AND MATH
TWO OTHER PRESCHOOLERS WITH DOWN
SYNDROME FINALLY ONE MAN IS THE
OWNER OF HIS OWN RESTAURANT.
AFTER GRADUATING FROM COLLEGE
WAS CERTIFICATES AND FOOD
SERVICES OFFICE SKILLS
RESTAURANT HOSTING AND THIS
PERSON ALSO STARTED A FOUNDATION
TO HELP OTHERS WITH DISABILITIES --
STARTING THEIR OWN BUSINESSES
FRIENDS AND COLLEAGUES THANK YOU
FOR YOUR ATTENTION AND
RECOGNITION OF THIS VERY
IMPORTANT CONDITION I ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT ACR.
FIFTY THREE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR FIRST ROLL CALL TO BE OPEN
FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK.
THANK YOU MISS GRAYSON MEMBERS.
THE HOUSE WILL BE IN ORDER
PLEASE KEEP YOUR CONVERSATIONS
TO A MINIMUM MISTER FRAZIER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES.
IT'S MY GREAT PLEASURE TO RISE
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF ACR.
FIFTY THREE IT'S A SPECIAL DAY
RECOGNITION FOR THE INTELLECTUAL
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
COMMUTE.
COMMUNITY.
WE ALL HAVE MET A PERSON WITH
DOWN SYNDROME AT WORK.
AT SCHOOL AND IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
OUR FRIENDS WITH DOWN SYNDROME
BRING LAUGHTER.
CERTAINLY JOY AND CONTRIBUTING
MEMBERS OF OUR SOCIETY.
AND THEY REMIND US TO APPRECIATE
THE LITTLE MOMENTS.
OF OUR DAY.
THAT'S WHY WE MUST REMEMBER TO
CONTINUE INCLUDING INDIVIDUALS
WITH EXTRA ORDINARY ABILITIES.
IN OUR EVERYDAY CONVERSATIONS.
I WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE
FROM CONCORD FOR BRINGING THIS
IMPORTANT RESOLUTION FORWARD BUT
ALSO WOULD LIKE TO THANK HIS
SISTER. FOR RAISING A WONDERFUL
BROTHER.
I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT AC FIFTY
EIGHT A. C. R. FIFTY THREE IN
RECOGNIZING OUR FRIENDS.
WITH DOWN SYNDROME.
THANK YOU MISTER FRAZIER.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MISTER RATIONS ASKING
THAT THE FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR
CO AUTHORS THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE RUN.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON ABC
ARE.
FIFTY THREE THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS.
CLICK WELL CLOSE RATHER SEVENTY
THREE CO AUTHORS ADDED AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE.
ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THAT RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED AND MISTER GRAYSON
YOUR AGAIN RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GUESTS INTRODUCTION THANK YOU
MISTERCHAIR AND COLLEAGUES I
RISE AGAIN TO RECOGNIZE A FEW
MEMBERS CARE TAKERS.
AND ADVOCATES WHO ARE PART OF
THIS WONDERFUL DOWN SYNDROME
COMMUNITY AND THEY'RE HERE WITH
US TODAY I WOULD LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE THE FOLLOWING GUEST IN
THE GALLERY AND THEIR FIRST AND
THE RESPECTIVE ORGANIZATIONS.
ALEX RIVEN ALONG WITH MAYOR --
RECESS ERICKSON AND MARY
ERICKSON FROM THE ASSOCIATION OF
REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES ALONG
WITH ERIN KELLY KATIE LADEN FROM
CHILDREN SPECIALTY CARE
COALITION ALISON OLSON JUNE
OLSON AND ADDITIONAL FAMILY
MEMBERS.
FROM THE DOWN SYNDROME
INFORMATION ALLIANCE AS WELL AS
A LISTA KESSLER FROM THE SPECIAL
OLYMPICS NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
FRIENDS AND COLLEAGUES PLEASE
TAKE A MOMENT TO WELCOME THESE
WONDERFUL WONDERFUL FOLKS TO OUR
CAPITAL THEIR CAPITAL THANK
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO A VOTE
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
DOES ANY MEMBER WISH REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND DAY
CONSENT CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE TWENTY FOUR
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BIGELOW AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE PEACE
OFFICERS.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON THE
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR ALL
MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS BETTER DESIRED ABOUT
THIS IS CONSENT [inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSER ALL.
I SEVENTY KNOWS YOUR OF THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
CLERK WILL READ THE REMAINING
ITEMS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX OH THREE I
SEVENTY NO ZERO INTO SIMPLY
JOINT RESOLUTION.
TO I SEVENTY NO.
ZERO MEMBERS OF THE ABSENCE OF
OBJECTION WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS A QUORUM CALL IS NOT
LIFTED THE QUORUM CALLS NOT
LIFTED.
AND MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS.
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE FLOOR.
WE ARE AND ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS MEMBERS.
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE FLOOR
.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY. TO ADJOURN THE MEMORY.
OF ALBERT MADRID.
TODAY.
ALBERT WAS A RESIDENT OF
HIGHLAND A LOVER OF MUSIC
ANIMALS IN HIS COMMUNITY.
ON MARCH NOT OUR MARCH NINTH HE
RUSHED INTO A BURNING MOBILE
HOME AND RESCUED FOR PEOPLE.
ALBERT GAVE OF HIS LIFE SAVING
OTHERS AS THE FLAMES CONSUMED
HIM.
HE PASSED AWAY AT THE YOUNG AGE
OF TWENTY FIVE ALBERT WAS BORN
IN SAM -- DINO ON DECEMBER
TWENTY NINTH.
NINETEEN NINETY THREE HE
ATTENDED ST GRIGORY ALL HIGH
SCHOOL AND GRADUATED FROM SAN
ANDREAS HIGH SCHOOL.
HE LOVE WORKING WITH HIS HANDS
AND SERVED AS THE NEIGHBORHOOD
MECHANIC AND MOST RECENTLY
WORKED AT THE TRADER JOE'S
WAREHOUSE AND SAMBAR TO DO YOU
KNOW.
ALBERT IS SURVIVED BY HIS MOTHER
IRENE FATHER ROBERT FOUR
SIBLINGS [inaudible]
MARIAH MARIO MELISSA ZACHARY AND
HIS GIRLFRIEND OF OVER FIVE
YEARS CYNTHIA.
HIS HEROIC ACTIONS SAVED HIS
NEIGHBORS AND SHOW WHAT A
SELFLESS AND CARING YOUNG MAN HE
WAS.
ALBERT MADRID WILL BE MISSED BY
ALL OF US IN THE INLAND EMPIRE.
I ASKED THAT WE ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF ALBERT MADRID
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS ROSS.
MR O'DONNELL.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF HELEN JANE MCRAE.
MOTHER MY GOOD FRIEND AND
NEIGHBOR BRUCE MCRAE.
HELEN WAS BORN ON NOVEMBER
FOURTH NINETEEN TWENTY SIX AND
YOUNGSTOWN OHIO.
SHE WAS THE FIFTH OF SIX
CHILDREN AND GREW UP IN A HOME
FILLED WITH MUSIC AND SONG.
MUSIC WOULD BECOME A LIFELONG
PASSION FOR HELEN.
IN NINETEEN FORTY SIX HELEN AND
HER FAMILY LEFT OHIO AND MOVED
TO THE BELMONT SHORE
NEIGHBORHOOD.
OF LONG BEACH CALIFORNIA.
HELLO QUICKLY EMBRACE LIFE.
BY THE OCEAN.
HELEN AND HER SISTERS MADE A
PROFESSIONAL CAREER OUT OF THEIR
LOVE FOR MUSIC.
THE SHERLOCK SISTERS SANG FOR
WEDDINGS BENEFITS YOU SO SHOWS
AND OF COURSE FOR THE SAINT
BARTHOLOMEW CHURCH CHOIR.
IN BELMONT SHORE.
WHILE WORKING IN THE NAPLES GRAN
MARKET NINETEEN FIFTY HELEN MET
HER HUSBAND BOB MCRAE.
THE COUPLE MARRIED IN NINETEEN
FIFTY ONE AND EVENTUALLY SETTLED
IN EAST LONG BEACH WHERE THEY
WOULD RACE FOUR CHILDREN
TOGETHER.
THOUGH HELEN WAS ALWAYS PROUD OF
THE MUSIC SHE AND HER SISTERS
PERFORMED RAISING HER FOUR
CHILDREN IN A WARM AND LOVING
ENVIRONMENT.
WAS YOUR GREATEST ACCOMPLISHMENT.
HELEN WILL BE REMEMBERED FOR HER
WARM SMILE INFECTIOUS LAUGH.
ENTER ALSO SINGING VOICE ALWAYS
IN PERFECT HARMONY.
SHE IS SURVIVED BY HER CHILDREN
VALERIE ROBBIE BRUCE IN BERRY.
SEVEN GRANDCHILDREN AND ONE
GREAT GRANDCHILD.
I ASKED THAT WE ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF ONE WHO LED A GREAT
LIFE.
AND WHO LOVE MUCH HELEN MCRAE.
THANK YOU MISTER DONALD
[inaudible]
MISTER GIBSON.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR GERMAN
MEMORY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS ARE RISE TO
**** BODY TO ADJOURN.
IN MEMORY.
OF GENET.
LURCH.
A LONG TIME RESIDENTS OF THE
CITY OF LONG BEACH GENET WAS THE
WIFE OF FORMER.
OF LONG BEACH CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER AND VICE MAYOR VAL LURCH.
I SHE WORKED TO LONG BEACH
MEMORIAL.
HOSPITAL.
OF OVER TWENTY YEARS IN THE
BREAST CENTER BREAST CANCER WARD.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND THREE SHE
WAS DIAGNOSED WITH M. S..
AND SADLY SHE LOST HER BATTLE TO
EN MASSE.
ON MARCH THE FOURTH TWO THOUSAND
AND NINETEEN GENET SIR IS
SURVIVED BY HER HUSBAND VAL
LURCH HER TWO CHILDREN.
AND THREE GRANDCHILDREN SHE
TOUCHED THE HEARTS AND MINDS OF
MANY WHO KNEW HER.
AND ALL WILL MOURN HER LOSS --
JUST A QUICK NOTE -- VAL EVERY
TIME I WOULD GIVE HIM A CALL THE
FORMER CITY COUNCIL MEMBER.
AND I WOULD ALWAYS ASK ABOUT HIS
WIFE.
AND HE WOULD SAY WHAT HE'S DOING
FOR HER -- HE EXEMPLIFIED -- THE
GREAT HUSBAND. TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE ONE BAITING HER.
TAKE HER TO THE RESTROOM AND
THINGS OF THAT NATURE HE WAS
ALWAYS THERE -- WHICH GIVES
GREAT MEANING TO UNTIL DEATH DO
US PART I WAS CERTAINLY ****
BODY ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF
GENET FOR LUNCH.
THANK YOU MISTER GIBSON.
MISTER PATTERSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR GERMAN A MEMORY.
I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS PLEASE.
I JOIN WITH ME TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY FOR ONE OF FRESNO STATE'S
MOST DEVOTED BULLDOGS FREDERICK
GEORGE STEIN.
FRED PASSED AWAY ON MARCH THE
FIRST AT HIS HOME HE WAS NINETY
YEARS OLD.
FRED WAS ACTUALLY A SAN JOSE
STATE UNIVERSITY GRADUATE.
BUT HIS HEART BELONGED TO FRESNO
STATE.
FLAGS ON THE CAMPUS WERE FLOWN
AT HALF STAFF AFTER HIS PASSING
TO HONOR HIS SIX DECADES OF
DEDICATION TO HIS BELOVED BOTOX.
FRED SERVED AS THE PRESIDENT OF
BOTH THE FRESNO STATE ALUMNI
ASSOCIATION.
AND THE BULLDOG FOUNDATION.
HE WAS HONORED IN TWO THOUSAND
AND SIX WITH A LIFETIME
ACHIEVEMENT AWARD BY THE FRESNO
STATE BULLDOGS FOUNDATION.
HE ALSO ENJOYED SERVING OUR
COMMUNITY IN A VARIETY OF WAYS
PARTICULARLY IN HIS CAPACITY
WITH THE SOUTH FRESNO LIONS CLUB.
FRED RETIRED FROM PART DAVIS
AFTER NEARLY FORTY YEARS.
HE WAS LOVED BY ALL WHO KNEW HIM
FOR ITS PASSION FOR HIS FAMILY
FOR SERVICE AND FOR OUR
COMMUNITY WAS EVIDENT IN THE
WONDERFUL LIFE.
OF SERVICE HE LIVED HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS LOVING WIFE OF
SIXTY THREE YEARS DM HIS TWO
SONS.
AND HIS SISTERS PLEASE JOIN ME
AND FRESNO CALIFORNIA FRESNO
STATE.
AS WE MOURN HIS LOSS AND AS WE
ADJOURN THIS -- BODY IN HIS
MEMORY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS PATTERSON.
MISS RACE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS.
I RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN THE
MEMORY OF MY FRIEND PHILLY BUT
THE SINCE YOU.
WHO DIED IN AN AIRPLANE CRASH IN
THE TO HAVE TO BE MOUNTAINS
FEBRUARY TWENTY FIRST?
AT THE AGE OF FIFTY THREE PHILIP
WAS BORN AND ABOUT THE LINE HOW
DO YOU SCHOOL MAY HE GO IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE AND
IMMIGRATED TO SANTA ANA.
AT THE AGE OF SEVEN HE LATER
WENT ON TO GRADUATE FROM WHAT
LOS AMIGOS HIGH SCHOOL IN
FOUNTAIN VALLEY AND CAL STATE
FULLERTON.
WE PARTICIPATED IN STUDENT
ORGANIZATIONS TO ADVOCATE ON
BEHALF OF LATINO AND OTHER
MINORITY STUDENTS.
IT WAS A CAL STATE FULLERTON
THAT HE ALSO MET AND MARRIED IS
SWEET HEART YOUR LONG THE BENITO.
PHILIPPE THERE WAS IT LIKE
MYSELF A GRADUATE OF LOYOLA LAW
SCHOOL WHERE YOU CONTINUE TO
ADVOCATE FOR MINORITIES.
AND IN PARTICULAR FOCUSED ON
ISSUES THAT IMPACTED THE WORKING
POOR.
AND UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES.
UPON GRADUATION PHILLIPA
CONTINUE TO SERVE HIS COMMUNITY
AS A LOS ANGELES COUNTY DEPUTY
PUBLIC DEFENDER.
AND WAS THE DEPUTY CITY ATTORNEY
FOR THE CITY OF COMPTON BEFORE
OPENING HIS OWN PRACTICE.
GIVING BACK TO HIS COMMUNITY.
WAS A PASSION OF PHILIP IS THAT
HE CARRIED HIS ENTIRE LIFE.
HE REGULARLY LECTURED AT THE
GERRY SPENCE TRIAL LAWYERS A
COLLEGE WHERE HE MENTORED LAW
STUDENTS AND NEW LAWYERS.
HE WAS ACTIVE IN CALIFORNIA
POLITICS I WAS PRESIDENT OF THE
MEXICAN AMERICAN BAR ASSOCIATION
POLITICAL ACTION COMMITTEE OR
MOTHER PACK.
FROM TWO THOUSAND FIVE TWO IS
PASSING.
AND IN TWO THOUSAND NINE WAS
NAMED ATTORNEY OF THE YEAR.
HE RAISE THE VISIBILITY OF
MOTHER PACK ACROSS CALIFORNIA
AND ENSURED THAT REGARDLESS OF
POLITICAL AFFILIATION.
THE ORGANIZATION ENDORSED
CANDIDATES THAT WOULD SERVE THE
COMMUNITIES HE CARED SO
PASSIONATELY.
FOR PHILLIPPI WILL BE REMEMBERED
FOR BY MANY FOR HIS DOWN TO
EARTH YET RELENTLESS ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF HIS CLIENTS.
AS WELL AS HIS BELIEF THAT ALL
LAWYERS MUST EMPATHIZE WITH ALL
THOSE INVOLVED IN THE LEGAL
PROCESS.
AND UNDERSTAND ALL PERSPECTIVES.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
YOLANDA HIS DAUGHTER'S MAGALI
AND ELENA.
HIS FATHER ROUGH I IN AND HIS
SIBLINGS.
RAMON DRAW SOME MORE SAYS STUFF
I AND JOSEPH AND ERICA.
WE WILL MISS PHILLY PAY AND IS
BIGGER THAN LIFE PRESENCE IN
CALIFORNIA.
HE HAS GONE TOO SOON.
THANK YOU ADDRESS MISTER GIBSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- IS
SPEAKER MEMBERS I JUST FOUND OUT
THAT MY FRIEND PASSED AWAY LEAVE
A WAS INTO.
ARE JUST READING OF THE THE
ADJOURNMENTS AND WENT TO MISS
REYES AND **** THIS FROM MY
FRIEND -- HIS IT HE WAS A GREAT
MAN.
I KNOW HIS WIFE HIS CHILDREN HIS
PARENTS -- WE HAVE A LONG
RELATIONSHIP TOGETHER -- HIS
SISTER -- IS -- WORKING APPARENT
CENTER I ONE OF OUR SCHOOLS IN
MY COMMUNITY.
WHEN SHE FOUND OUT THAT I KNEW
HER BROTHER?
HER BROTHER WAS THE FAMILY'S
HERO -- SHE LOOKED UP TO HIM SHE
JESS POURED OUT SO MUCH
ENTHUSIASM ABOUT HER BROTHER I
WHICH IS HER LITTLE BROTHER SHE
WAS THE OLDEST -- SIBLING IN THE
FAMILY AND TO HEAR THAT HE'S
PASSED AWAY CERTAINLY -- I WANT
TO ECHO EVERYTHING THAT I WAS
THE ONLY WOMAN RACES INDICATED --
WE HAVE LOST A GREAT GM IN OUR
COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU MS GIBSON THANK YOU
MEMBERS.
PLEASE BRING THE NAMES OF THE
DESK TO BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL.
OUR CRESTWOOD JOURNAL MEMORY
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL.
ANNOUNCEMENTS THE SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS TUESDAY
MARCH TWENTY FIFTH.
HURRY TUESDAY MARCH TWENTY SIXTH
CHECK IN SESSION WEDNESDAY MARCH
TWENTY SEVENTH CHECK IN SESSION
THURSDAY MARCH TWENTY EIGHTH
FLOOR SESSION.
IS AT NINE AM ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED RETAIN
ALL MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SECONDARY NO FURTHER BUSINESS
I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
TO ADJOURN.
MR HOLDEN MOVES AND MISS WALDRON
SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY MARCH
TWENTY EIGHTH AT NINE AM IN THE
QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED
THIS VOTE
CHANGE.
AB FIFTY FOUR I TO KNOW.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MATHIS ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTY FOUR
I TO KNOW